[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serien einen schönen guten Abend
katja ist wieder mit mir im Studio und
hat gleich den sonntagssport und der war
vielfältig schönen guten Abend wir
blicken gemeinsam auf die Themen
der Versuch einer Annäherung
US-Außenminister blinken spricht bei
seinem Besuch in China aber auch über
strittige Themen wie Pekings
Militärmanöver vor Taiwan
ein Auftritt schlägt Wellen
Eisschnellläuferin und Bundespolizistin
Claudia Pechstein sorgt für Diskussionen
mit einer Rede in Uniform bei der CDU
und mit Spaß am Sport in Berlin haben
die Special Olympics begonnen eine Woche
lang zeigen Athleten mit geistigen
Beeinträchtigungen ihr Können
[Musik]
das Verhältnis zwischen den Supermächten
USA und China kühlte sich zuletzt immer
weiter ab darum richten sich die Blicke
jetzt nach Peking wo US-Außenminister
blinken heute einen im Februar
abgesagten Besuch nachholt belastet wird
das Verhältnis ja durch mehrere Themen
etwa den Umgang Pekings mit Taiwan oder
der Haltung chines zum russischen
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine und dann
war da noch die balanceaffäre die USA
warfen den Chinesen im Februar Spionage
vor und schossen einen angeblichen
Wetterballon ab über diesen schwierigen
Besuch jetzt Elisabeth Schmidt
der chinesische Außenminister kommt dem
amerikanischen ein paar Schritte
entgegen begrüßt ihn an der Tür des
Gästehauses nicht wie sonst üblich im
Inneren der Villa die Gespräche danach
sie suchen nach einem Minimalkonsens vor
seinem Abflug formulierte blinken diesen
so
du bist
eine offene klare Kommunikation zwischen
unseren beiden Ländern zu etablieren
damit wir mögliche Missverständnisse und
fehlkommunikationen vermeiden
gemeint vor allem der Konflikt im
Indopazifik in der Taiwanstraße kamen
sich in den vergangenen Wochen
chinesische und amerikanische Kampfjets
und Militärschiffe gefährlich nahe China
fühlt sich eingeengt militärisch und
wirtschaftlich
in der Tat signalisiert Peking doch
durch seine Rhetorik dass es sich
bedroht fühlt auch gehemmt in seiner ja
weiteren Entwicklung und das ist
natürlich eher ein Zeugnis von
Unsicherheit das Peking dort an den Tag
legt doch in den vergangenen Wochen gab
es auch Hoffnung für die
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen eine Reihe von
amerikanischen Wirtschaftsbossen wurde
in China empfangen auch die beiden
Außenminister bemühen sich heute um die
Eskalation
blinken habe zehn Gang zu einem
Gegenbesuch in Washington eingeladen
hieß es nach dem Treffen von
amerikanischer Seite laut chinesischen
Staatsmedien ging es auch um die
Verhandlungen weiterer Flugverbindungen
zwischen den USA und China und um mehr
Visa für Geschäftsreisende und
Studierende
kleine Schritte in einem festgefahrenen
Konflikt allein dass die USA und China
wieder an einem gemeinsamen Tisch sitzen
ist ein kleiner Erfolg
die CDU diskutierte an diesem Wochenende
über ein neues Grundsatzprogramm dabei
ging es auch um die Frage wie man sich
von der AFD abgrenzt ein umstrittener
Auftritt von eisschnellläuferin Claudia
Pechstein in Uniform schlägt jetzt hohe
Wellen und verleiht der Diskussion neuen
Auftrieb Frank Buchwald
cdu-konvent der Wochenende in Berlin
mittendrin eine Frau in Uniform Claudia
Pechstein 51 5-fache Olympiasiegerin
Bundespolizistin Pechstein spricht viel
über Sportpolitik dann aber fallen auch
Sätze wie dieser
gehört zum Beispiel gehört zu den
Alltagsproblem die viele besonders
ältere Menschen unter Frauen belasten
zögern dabei Fall für viele auch in der
CDU klingt das nach Populismus für
manche gar nach AFD der Parteichef aber
stark Pechstein den Rücken
der Auftritt war brillant und Claudia
Pechstein hat uns noch mal aus ihrer
Erfahrung gesagt wie wichtig Sport
Vereine Breitensport sind und ehrlich
gesagt das interessiert mich wirklich
das Äußere interessiert mich nicht dass
äußere damit ist die Polizeiuniform
gemeint viel Kritik dafür nicht nur auf
Twitter unter dem Hashtag
Neutralitätspflicht etwa schreibt der
SPD Abgeordnete Sebastian Fiedler selbst
Polizeibeamter ich reibe mir ungläubig
die Augen und Petra Pau von der
Linkspartei kritisiert dieser Vorgang
liege außerhalb jeder tolerablen
Möglichkeit laut Beamtengesetz haben
Beamte sich bei politischer Betätigung
zurückzuhalten das Innenministerium
wollte sich zunächst nicht äußern die
Bundespolizei aber prüfe
dienstrechtliche Schritte heißt es heute
in Berlin
die Zahl der Menschen die Gewalt durch
Partner Ex Partner oder Angehöriger
erfahren ist stark angestiegen laut Welt
am Sonntag wurden im vergangenen Jahr in
Deutschland mehr als 179.000 Fälle
häuslicher Gewalt registriert das sind
9,3% mehr als 2021 zwei Drittel der
Opfer seinen Frauen die dunkelste war
gilt als hoch weil sich viele nicht
trauen Anzeige zu erstatten
die Schweizer haben in einer
Volksabstimmung für ein Gesetz gestimmt
dass ihr Land bis 2050 klimaneutral
machen soll knapp 59% sprachen sich für
das sogenannte Klima- und
innovationsgesetz aus mit dem der
Verbrauch von Öl und Gas schrittweise
gesenkt werden soll sowohl Bürger als
auch Unternehmen können mit finanzieller
Unterstützung rechnen wenn Sie sich für
klimafreundliche Alternativen
entscheiden
nach dem Bruch des kachowka Staudamms in
der Ukraine ist die Zahl der Toten laut
ukrainischen Behörden in der Region auf
16 gestiegen dort und in angrenzenden
Gebieten ist nicht nur die Infrastruktur
stark beschädigt oder gar nicht
vernichtet sondern auch die
Existenzgrundlage vieler Menschen so wie
in der Hafenstadt Nikopol am karowka
Stausee zu dem macht die Sicherheitslage
den Einwohnern in der Nähe des
Atomkraftwerks zu schaffen Alisa jung
berichtet
zwei Stunden steht Natalia die der Rover
manchmal an seitdem Staudamm Bruch ist
die Wasserversorgung in Nikopol komplett
zusammengebrochen nun müssen sie Wasser
zum Kochen und Waschen in Kanistern
sammeln gehen
heute habe ich versucht die
Waschmaschine zu füllen irgendwas zu
finden wie ich das machen kann aber es
funktioniert nie so muss ich mit der
Hand waschen
auf der anderen Seite des Stausees steht
das Atomkraftwerk von saporisha russisch
besetzt waren die Ukrainer hier in
nicopol und die russischen Truppen
gegenüber bislang durch eine riesige
Wasserfläche getrennt sieht es jetzt so
aus seit einem Jahr wird die Stadt
beschossen über 30 Grad und fast kein
Wasser mehr zwischen Nikopol und dem
Atomkraftwerk hier riecht es nach
modrigem abgestandenen Wasser es ist
unglaublich heiß und zusätzlich zu der
Sorge vor Beschuss der Sorge vor einer
nuklearen Katastrophe haben die Menschen
hier nicopol gar kein Trinkwasser mehr
der Chef der Internationalen
Atomenergiebehörde besuchte das AKW am
Donnerstag und gab für den Moment
Entwarnung die Kühlung des AKWs sei
zunächst nicht in Gefahr trotzdem macht
sich Natalia die der Robert große Sorgen
um die Zukunft ihrer Heimat ich habe
auch Angst dass die die dort sitzen
diese ungebetenen Gäste zu Fuß hier
hinkommen werden nicht weit von hier
kämpft die Ukraine heftig um die
Eroberung der besetzten Gebiete der
Beschuss das AKW die Wasserversorgung
zumindest dafür versucht die Stadt eine
Lösung zu finden solange sind sie auf
ihre Feuerwehr angewiesen
so jetzt zu einem besonderen Event Katja
in Berlin wurden gestern die Special
Olympics World Games eröffnet genau und
das war ein lauter und in vielerlei
Hinsicht bunter Abend im Olympiastadion
rund 7000 Athletinnen und Athleten mit
geistiger Beeinträchtigung aus 190
Ländern werden in den nächsten 7 Tagen
das hauptstadtleben bereichern
die erste Goldmedaille bei diesen
Special Olympics verdienten sich alle
Athleten der Eröffnungsfeier durch ihre
grenzenlose Freude und Begeisterung beim
Einzug der teilnehmenden Nation mit
ihrem riesigen Enthusiasmus steckten sie
auch die 50.000 Zuschauer im Stadion an
so dass die Eröffnungsfeier zu einer
bunten Party wurde die Athleten mit
geistiger Behinderung präsentierten sich
mit rührender Offenheit so auch ein
syrischer Sportler der Tim Schreiber den
Vorsitzenden der Special Olympics
Bewegung mitten in seiner Rede umarmte
dafür gab es nicht etwa einen Verweis
sondern großen Beifall beim Sportfest
des Special Olympics Familie
Tennisspielerin Sophie renzmann
entzündete das olympische Feuer für
Spiele bei denen nicht gegen sondern
miteinander um Medaille gekämpft wird
[Musik]
ja und tennis ist ein gutes Stichwort
Tennisprofi Jan Lennart Struff wollte
seinen ersten Titel auf der ATP-Tour
doch der US-Amerikaner Frances Tier hat
er beim Turnier in Stuttgart dann doch
andere Pläne den ersten Satz gewann noch
mit sechs zu vier und dann wurde es
packen denn hier vor gewann den nächsten
und auch den entscheidenden dritten Satz
hauchdünn im Tie-Break aber trotzdem
Niederlage ist Stufe jetzt besser
Deutscher in der Weltrangliste auf Platz
10 Kämpfer Niklas Carol hat das
Mehrkampf meeting in Ratingen gewonnen
und als zweiter Deutscher Zehnkämpfer
nach Leo Neugebauer die Olympia-Norm für
die Spiele in Paris im kommenden Jahr
geschafft dafür musste er sich im
abschließenden 1500 Meter Lauf aber
ordentlich strecken mit der Volk Karl
übernahm 500 m vor dem Ziel die Führung
lief Meeting Rekord und holte 8484
Punkte 24 mehr als für Olympia
erforderlich
ja und heute wurde die erste Runde im
DFB-Pokal ausgelost und wieso oft gibt
es einige interessante Begegnungen so
spielt der Rekordmeister Bayern München
zunächst bei Drittliga Aufsteiger
Preußen Münster
Pokalsieger RB Leipzig ist bei 2 Liga
Aufsteiger Wiesbaden zu Gast
regionallig ist Lok Leipzig empfängt
Eintracht Frankfurt und oberlig ist wir
haben es gesehen SV Oberachern
bundesliga
[Applaus]
die Welt von Andreas Kössen die Spiele
dann am 12 August und alle Ansetzungen
sehen Sie in der heute App oder auf
heute.de
wir haben noch die Wetteraussichten
morgen gibt es viel Sonne von der
Nordsee bis zum Thüringer Wald und im
Südwesten aber auch einige Schauer und
Gewitter dabei ist es 26 bis 32 Grad
warm an den Küsten etwas kühler
ab 21:45 Uhr ist heute journal mit Dunja
Hayali schönen Dank fürs Interesse
schönen Abend und jetzt schön dran
bleiben bei Berlin direkt mit Theo Paul